some of its fastest growing economies
as many british prime ministers before
me and of course both her majesty the
queen and the prince of wales have
recognized
there are few forums more quietly
important for our nation's peace
prosperity
and global influence we benefit from the
incredible commonwealth advantage the
fertilizer i talked about yesterday of
shared language and institutions which
opens doors
and cuts the cost of doing business
we want to seize those opportunities and
that's why i announced this week
major new investments in
new british investments in green
infrastructure projects as well as trade
schemes designed to break down the
barriers to doing business
this is where the uk is positioning
ourselves post-brexit
in close alliance with our european
neighbours but also deepening our ties
with old friends in asia africa the
caribbean and the pacific
more trade
more commerce brings prosperity and
stability to other countries
but it also cuts costs for british
consumers and opens opportunities for uk
business so jobs and growth at home as
well
unfortunately that global prosperity and
stability
is being threatened by vladimir putin's
unprovoked assault on ukraine
many of the countries represented here
in kigali today
find themselves bearing the brunt
of putin's folly
their populations brought closer to
poverty by spiraling food and energy
costs
i know of course uh and deeply
appreciate understand that families
businesses in the uk have been hit hard
as well by the rising costs of living
and that's why in our country our
chancellor has introduced an
unprecedented package of financial
support for the most vulnerable
households
but we should also recognize the
challenges around the world
the un
estimates that an additional 48 million
people will be pushed into acute hunger
this year that is to the point of
starvation
caused by climate change and post
pandemic supply shortages but also
by the war
in ukraine
i spoke to president zolensky last week
in kiev about how we can unblock
russia's a blockade of ukraine grain
exports but
today we're announcing a new 372 million
package of uk aid and that funding will
support the un's emergency response in
the hardest hit countries as well as
providing cutting-edge science
partnerships to look at drought
resistant crops and new agricultural
techniques and
as i
go
tomorrow night to the to the g7 in
germany
we will also be looking at what more
the richer countries can do to bring
down global commodity prices and
increase food supplies to get the world
economy back on track and stick up at
the same time for the freedoms in which
we all believe thank you very much i'm
going to go uh i've got quite a few
questions here from alex let's go first
to alex forsyth of the bbc
you prime minister you've been talking
about the work that you were doing on
the global stage but isn't it the
reality that some voters don't like the
work that you're doing at home you've
lost what was a solid conservative seat
you've lost a seat you won less than
three years ago and you've lost your
party chairman have you considered prime
minister that perhaps you are part of
the problem i think that of course uh
people are going to want to look at you
know political impacts and
the impact on uh party politics of these
uh of these by-elections but i just
remind you of the context in which uh
we're operating uh the world in the as
i've just said the uk other parts of the
world are facing the price shocks caused
by uh not just the supply chain problems
we've seen postcode but also by uh the
war in in ukraine uh we're dealing with
those with a huge amount of fiscal
firepower so 1200 pounds for the 8
million most vulnerable households
coming into people's bank accounts
next month
tax cuts for
the vast majority of people paying
national insurance contributions and
also of course focusing on the ways we
can as i said bear down on people's
costs more generally so look
i'm not going to pretend uh these are
brilliant results i'm we've got to
listen we've got to we've got to learn
but it wasn't that long ago uh only just
over a year ago though we won a
spectacular by-election victory when
people are finding it tough it they send
messages to politicians and politicians
have got to respond and that's what
we're doing i think the fundamentals in
the uk economy are good but we've got to
recognize uh that times are tough for
people right now but i think we have the
the right program the right uh plan for
a stronger economy to get our country uh
our country through it and uh and come
out stronger the other side
dan hewitt of itv
thank you prime minister um
you're defiant in defeat today but your
opponents
say you're delusional that you're now
putting your own interests ahead of the
party and the country your biggest asset
was that you're a winner now that you've
started losing what is boris johnson's
big asset look i think that what people
want is a government that focuses uh 100
on their concerns
and not on uh
political consequences in uh in
westminster and i've absolutely no doubt
that this is a government that has not
only
achieved remarkable things done some
very great things is going to continue
to do some great things for the people
of this of this country and
we're going through a tough time right
now we have inflationary pressures that
i i've talked about i understand
people's feelings but
we're going to get through them and you
know i just remind you we've got uh
still we've got uh people in payroll
employment uh 630 000 more than before
the pandemic began
what we've got to do is make sure that
we continue with the work that we're
doing to
help people in the short term
with the pressures they're facing
but also deal with the
issues in our supply chains issues in
our in our transport system in uh in our
housing market uh in our energy market
reform those things so as to bear down
on costs and make make things easier for
people and make our economy more
productive it's a massive agenda for
change and we're gonna we're gonna get
on with it kate ferguson of the sun
thanks prime minister two quick
questions if i may it's been a tough day
for you today was there any point you'd
considered resigning
and the main question if possible
obviously the unions are going on strike
in the airports now
do you think they're wrecking people's
summer holidays are you considering
bringing the military in to help
um staff airports now and also do you
think brits should stay kate if they
can't go away this summer because of the
union strikes thanks
thanks very much kate look uh with the
airlines like the railways got very
substantial uh sums of public money in
uh in support during the the pandemic i
think it was eight billion for uh the
airline 16 billion for the uh the
railways from from memory i don't think
there are justifications for these
strikes uh but i want what i want is is
for people to get around the table and
sort it out when you look at what's
happening on the on the railways as i've
said uh repeatedly i think the there's a
there's a overwhelming case for change
and reform and and improvement this is a
government that is putting huge sums
into our railways huge sums of taxpayers
money
are going into the roads 96 billion just
into the integrated rail plan for
railways in the north and the midlands i
think
taxpayers and fare payers have a right
to demand improvements in the way those
railways operate uh for that uh for that
investment and and that's what we're uh
we're gonna get martin brown of the
express
thank you prime minister um you had a
much anticipated meeting with prince
charles today did you manage to speak to
him about your rwanda asylum policy and
could you just uh describe how your
relationship is with the heir to the
throne yeah well look i mean you're
obviously i'm not going to go into what
happened with the the conversation that
that took place you obviously you know
it did take place i don't discuss uh
conversations either with her majesty
the queen uh or with uh over the air to
the throne uh you wouldn't expect that
but uh it was a it was a good old
chinwag and we certainly covered a lot
of ground and there's there's no doubt
that um uh you know when you look at
what you can certainly take away from uh
what the the prince had to say uh today
in his opening address to the to the
summit is that everyone can see the huge
huge progress that uh that rwanda has
made
claire ellicott of the mail
um thank you prime minister the
cabinet's been rather quiet today in
tweeting their support for you are you
confident that you still have their
backing and um also are you disappointed
about the baroness scotland re-election
thanks claire so look i mean first of
all uh the government i'm here in in in
rwanda uh
getting on with the uh the the chogham
summit which is incredibly important for
our country and for our world um
i hope that uh in london i know that in
london uh ministers of all descriptions
cabinet or otherwise are getting on with
the job of uh of sorting out uh the
cost of living pressures that people
face and delivering on our agenda for
for change and reform and improvement
and that's what they're that's what i i
would hope that they are doing uh on on
the um
uh
the secretary general of the
commonwealth look you know uh i think
it's a
uh
it's a good day for democracy uh where
where where
what what is the what is the uh what is
the commonwealth it is an amazing uh
group of 54
countries uh that share values and in
particular the idea of uh of of
democracy and i i work well with
baroness scotland uh have done for a
very long time since i became uh foreign
secretary i think and uh and look
forward to working well with her in the
in the next couple of years now
this is a crucial time uh for the
commonwealth i think those
people are looking more and more to this
institution more and more countries want
to join it they see the value of it and
so uh we'll be doing everything we can
simultaneously to help strengthen the
commonwealth secretariat and and really
deliver value for for commonwealth
members
committed turner telegraph
thank you prime minister um you're now
out of the country until next thursday
are you worried mps from your own party
are going to be plotting to get rid of
you while you're away and secondly
you've just lost what was a really safe
tory seat how are you going to stop blue
wall voters across the country voting
lib dem in the next general election
thanks so so but i think the the answer
to the answer first question is no but
the answer on the the second question is
what you have in this government is a
reforming government that is going to
that has done taken all sorts of very
difficult and tough decisions and uh if
you look at what we did during covert it
wasn't easy uh but we got some big
decisions right we had the first vaccine
of uh first approved vaccine i think of
any country
in the world we had the fastest vaccine
rollout in europe we came out of the uh
of covered faster than anybody else as
i've told you we now have very low
unemployment by historic standards uh
we're getting some big things done we
were the first
european country to see the the vital
importance of of helping the the
ukrainians but what people
are going to get from this government
and they're going to get from me is
absolutely an undivided energy and
attention on fixing the issues uh in the
uk economy that cause unnecessary uh
cost and not just for uh for consumers
uh but for people who need uh childcare
uh and uh for businesses as well
the uk is attracting huge huge sums of
investment right now uh much more tech
investment than any other country much
more much more in europe a much more
venture capital uh investment even than
china we're making there are some things
that are going really really well but
there are some parts of our system that
need change
and reform and the energy market is one
the housing market is one our transport
system is another all these have impacts
on people's costs of living and we can
do things that will really help and of
course the biggest single
expenditure that people have the
households have is taxation that's the
biggest chunk that uh they contribute uh
we want to get and we are the party that
believes in cutting taxes where the
government believes in cutting taxes and
we want to get into a situation where
sensibly
and responsibly
we can
turbo charge the attractions of the uk
as a place to come and invest by having
the the best possible tax framework as
well for businesses and for and for for
families darren mccaffrey gb news
thank you very much prime minister and
are you in denial then about the
election results i mean in the sense
that most voters lots of tory mps don't
think this is simply about
government policy but it's about you
that you are a drag to some on the
conservative vote you at least accept in
part that narrative is true
and second of all on rwanda and the
migrant scheme we heard from the rwanda
government yesterday that they had
received and spent 120 million from the
british government
have they received the money and second
of all if no migrants are sent here can
we claw that money back was that 120
million pounds essentially gone for good
thanks so look first of all
on uh
my attitude to the
to buy elections i you know if
governments uh crumpled because of
by-election results in the whole of the
post-war period we wouldn't have had
many post-war uh governments and that
i'm afraid of course we need to to
listen to the messages that we're
getting we need to to learn uh but
in the end we've got to get on and
deliver for the british people and that
is that is what we are uh we're doing
and um
on your point about the
the rwanda immigration and economic uh
partnership
uh economic development partnership
it has many facets uh i'm confident that
the migration aspect will work very well
i think that it's notable that so far no
uk court has found it to be unlawful
and no international court has found it
to be unlawful
so i'm confident that we will be able to
to go ahead and
build develop a solution that i think
whose time has come if you look at the
problems that the world faces with
illegal migration you can see that other
countries it's not just us in the uk
yeah where we're out in front but other
countries are trying this
and you see you see what uh what joe
biden's been doing uh in the us uh an
idea for people coming from mexico to to
go to spain you see the danes are doing
something uh very similar
you've got to find a way of breaking the
model of the people smugglers
people smugglers people traffickers are
doing a profoundly evil and dangerous
thing
and you have to find a way of
of stopping that so we're going to we're
going to continue with the policy and
i'm you know you talk about we know will
we get a refund i'm confident that it
will uh produce value for money the
current
cost of the asylum system in our country
is about 1.5 billion and i think uh
5 million every day at least on on hotel
bills uh so you know this this is a very
very expensive
business already and i think the
the rwanda partnership offers a a good a
good way forward esther weber politico
thank you prime minister um i was
wondering if we could get your reaction
to
the decision by the supreme court
in america to overturn
roe v wade and whether you think
abortion rights
should be protected
by the state
sorry yes um uh esther look i i've been
absolutely
clear with everybody this is not our
court it's another it's another
jurisdiction but clearly it has massive
impacts uh on people's uh thinking
around the world it's a very important
decision i've got to tell you i think
it's a big step backwards i think it's a
big step backwards i've i've always
believed in a woman's right to choose
and
i stick to that view and that's why the
the uk has the the laws that it does and
actually if you look we we recently took
steps to make sure that uh those laws
were uh were enforced throughout the
whole of the of the uk
henry zeppelin the times
you were talking earlier uh prime
minister about uh wanting to cut taxes
that's going to ring quite hollow uh not
only to the many conservative mps who
want you gone but also to lots of voters
when the tax base is the highest it's
been in decades so
or tax burden rather so can you be a bit
more specific yeah our tax is going to
start falling for voters next year henry
let me let me let me tell you what's
happening now and first of all i think
most people like you know i've tried to
spell out the fiscal context that we're
we're operating in uh you know we went
through
a uh a really miserable and expensive
pandemic i've given you the figures for
the amount of taxpayers money we've had
to put just into the railways or or
aviation that doesn't grow on trees 408
billion altogether we had to find to
support families businesses up and down
the the country but at the same time
thanks to the sensible management of the
economy that uh rishi has been engaged
on we're able now next month you ask
when henry next month
you'll see tax cuts of an average of 330
pounds of uh of everybody who pays
national insurance contributions uh
we're already cutting council tax uh by
150 pounds uh work we've cut fuel duty
uh by record amount and you know i say
that not in any way i know that that
won't uh slake your thirst uh
for
uh uh
satiate your uh your appetite
for for tax cuts uh but it it's it shows
the direction we're trying to to go in
but you know
you've got to be sensible and you've got
to be responsible at the same time and
we're in a position still where we have
to make sure uh that we look after
people through uh through tough times
and that's why the 1200 pounds that
we're giving uh the most vulnerable
households is also very important
let's go to uh berna
bona
thank you prime minister my question
regards to your outgoing role as a
chair of the commonwealth do you take
responsibility
for abandoning the developing members of
their commonwealth during the pandemic
with travel bans
reluctance to share vaccines
reducing the eight budget the aid budget
and more recently the uk not availing
its
unused sdr reserves
thank you thank you very much well berna
actually i think when you look at what
the uk did during the the pandemic it
was it was it was pretty remarkable and
i know that um you know we would always
want to to do more uh but
particularly when it came to vaccines
that you you mentioned um uh we supplied
the people the the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine uh that was supplied
at cost thanks to the the deal that we
did with with astrazeneca thanks to the
investments we made in that project
1.4 billion doses were distributed
around the world it was it was the
world's most popular vaccine i think and
i mean i had it i don't know anybody
else about astrazeneca uh it it it was
it was something that was made possible
thanks to the uh the contribution of the
of the uk uh of uk
odor spending and i think that's a a
great great thing
um
james uh
but by the way my stakes as a outgoing
chair in office so you mentioned the uh
my job as chair and office of the of the
commonwealth i just want to pay a
particular tribute to rwanda uh for what
they're doing i think it has been a
fantastic uh summit so far and i wish
them uh every possible success i wish
president kagame every possible success
uh james karahanger from the new times
thank you prime minister
thank you prime minister
i had i listened to the responses you
gave the uk parliament a few
days ago about the question of
the genocide fugitives in your country
and i keep wondering
is
justice still
laid not just denied what's your take on
that is it even a common word value to
delay justice
for over two decades
thank you very much james and uh this
is a is a case of the uh the i think
it's the four genocide uh who are in who
are in london
and i answered a question in parliament
the other day and
uh look i went to the i went to the uh
the
genocide memorial uh yesterday and
nobody could go there without being
absolutely harrowed and uh by uh what
happened here in in rwanda i understand
people's feelings and so what i said to
president kagame yesterday is that i
will do everything i can to try to
expedite this it is in that so you
understand it's in the hands of the
metropolitan police uh i can't intervene
uh directly
but i will certainly be raising uh
raising it with them
i understand why uh people in in rwanda
feel the feel as you do
i i completely agree and
that's why uh i've said what i've said
to
uh
to to you uh to president uh kagami uh
if we can do anything more to bring uh
genocide
uh to justice then we will certainly do
that what i've said i will do is raise
it with the with the metropolitan police
and uh we're having as you know a new a
new head of the met uh very soon um
okay i'm gonna i was gonna knock it on
the head there but i can see i'll take
one more question from from from beth
and then and then from
he said
supporters were quite distressed and
disappointed by recent events and he
shared their feelings he said we cannot
carry on as business as usual and
someone should take responsibility and
then he said volunteers and staffers
deserve better than this
i know you've dismissed suggestions
you'd resign as crazy and you intend to
carry on anyone the confidence vote but
i imagine some colleagues back in london
might be pretty astonished watching this
press conference
given that you've been asked repeatedly
and you don't seem to acknowledge
that you could be
part of the problem you and your conduct
could be part of the problem uh with
voters why won't you acknowledge that i
mean you're safe you've won the
conference though can you not just leave
me let me try to give you give you give
you the best stance right now which is
that first of all on oliver uh i think
he
did a lot of uh good work particularly
as chairman about it also as as
secretary of state for uh dcms on
broadband rollout uh on uh veterans
affairs and other things i thank him for
uh for his service but i i genuinely
genuinely don't think uh the way forward
in british politics is to focus on
issues of
personalities whether they are mine or
others the way forward
is to make arguments to people about
change and improvement that we are
delivering and that is what i want to do
i think that the government has got some
difficult stuff right people are now
going through
a tough time we understand that i think
that we
have the the best way forward i think
that we understand how to fix our
economic issues how to uh make sure that
we have a a stronger economy and that is
what we're going to achieve i think some
signs are uh are promising but you know
i've got to be i've got to be clear with
people as i was during the the pandemic
i think um
it will take some time and there will
still be some some
some tough times ahead and no doubt uh
beth people will you know will continue
to to beat me up uh and and say this all
that about you know
to attack me that's fine that's quite
right that is the job of politicians in
the end uh voters journalists they have
no one else
to make their complaints to i have to i
have to take that but i also have to get
on uh with the job of delivering for the
for the people of this country and
that's what i was elected uh to do i'm
going to take one last question
prime minister my name is ethan i'm from
rwanda tv one um run at the uk are
working together on several development
projects as a matter of fact the uk is
the biggest donor in rwanda are you
satisfied with the results that you've
seen so far and your few days here and
uh what memories do you take with you
back home and if you could as well tell
us togo gabon and zimbabwe are
requesting to reject in the commonwealth
do you have the letters from the
meetings you had thank you well thank
you i i was longing to come to rwanda i
was very sad that the
the summit kept being postponed it has
certainly lived up to my uh expectations
it's an incredible country and uh
clearly the product of really
vaulting imagination
to take somewhere that we had really
been uh in the the very depths of
despair uh after the the genocides and
then to work and work and work to create
a a a culture
a an environment that is clean uh
focused on uh so many things so many
values that i think
are admirable so uh you know whatever
the the difficulties that may exist
between uh my country and and rwanda
about this all that and of course there
are going to be issues that were going
to continue to raise and quite quite
properly uh but my overwhelming
impression is of of a remarkable country
and i wish i'd been able to see uh to
see some of the the countryside but i i
haven't um uh uh
on an on your question about uh uh gabon
and togo we'll just have to uh to wait
and see and zimbabwe that is a matter
for the for the commonwealth and i've
taken two more thank you all very much
thank you thank you
okay so uh boris johnson they're
speaking in kigali he's at the
commonwealth heads
of government um
meeting um a lot of british press
traveling with the prime minister and a
lot obviously of questions about those
by-elections um
the um
wakefield loss to labor and tibetan
heart and being taken by the lib dems
and our own beth rigby actually they're
asking the prime minister about verdadon
and his resignation this morning um the
pm saying he did a lot of work i thank
him for him for his service but i don't
think the way forward on british
politics is to focus on personalities
the way forward is to make arguments on
change and improvement that we are
delivering so obviously and we're going
to be looking a lot more at what the pm
just said in rwanda but let's go back to
our other breaking story and
that is around the supreme court in the
u.s